implicitly captures like what you think
AGI oven is you know like some people
say yeah
sorry we are actually live now I forgot
to press the let's go live button my
apologies about that
um so anyway this is a very interesting
episode of mlst we're going to
experiment doing some live streams with
some folks from our community we have
some amazing experts in AGI in our
community and we're going to be
streaming for about an hour today
and um
we're going to have an intro from uh
cogchamp who's going to be the um the
main star of the show today he's going
to talk about some of his views on AGI
so symbolic versus connectionist and
cognitive architectures we're going to
talk about some technical details around
planning program synthesis and knowledge
representation and language and also
talk about AI risk and alignments
touching on
um the the threat of super intelligence
and some of the societal impacts of AI
so um anyway cogchamp is going to give
us their state of the nation so over to
you cogcham
we'll do that again eh so yeah thanks
for having me on Tim and
um yeah normally it's you saying this
but um
today the honor is mine to have a
conversation with uh the legendary Tim
scarf and Keith of course so yeah thanks
for having me on guys and um
so my name is Jacob Brooks and for the
last uh three and a half years I've been
an independent AI researcher with an
explicit focus on uh artificial general
intelligence and I post under the name
of champ on the mlst Discord server
where we talk about you know a bit of
everything really about Ai and
philosophy and politics and whatnot so
if any of that interests you
feel free to swing by so um yeah AGI
let's
um I think a good place for us to start
would actually be
our timelines for AGI actually because
it implicitly captures our beliefs about
you know what we think AGI even is you
know so like some people you're asking
there's a lot of pundits these days who
are saying you know like predicting 18
months like I know
um a well-known name
um on in the YouTube Community is David
Shapiro and he made a video about you
know three months ago saying that he was
predicting that agile would be here in
as little as 18 months so
September next year so pretty big call
in my opinion but um and then there are
people that say AGI is already here you
know look no further than
gpd4 for example so
but um for me personally I'd be very
surprised if we had AGI before
2040 to be honest I just think that
there's there's still far too much work
to go with in terms of like perception
and planning and combining it all into
like a robotics package that can
actually act and sense the real world I
think that's where a lot of the trouble
like a lot of the unsolved problems
still lie so
you know we've heard about the the
Wozniak test you know how Steve Wozniak
said like you know I'll I'll believe we
have AGI when a when a robot can come
into my house and make me a coffee and
give it to me and all that sort of thing
so I think that that's actually kind of
like on the right path uh as to you know
defining AGI like you know I I would
probably extend that and say you know
like I'll believe there's AGI when you
know I can tell that I can tell an AGI
that exists in America where I live and
it can you know book plane tickets it
can fly to my house and it can come in
and sit down and pick up an Xbox
controller and beat me in a game of Halo
2 or something you know like that's when
I would say that we would have something
resembling AGI and even then there'd
still be you know some things that are
probably
open for debate there like in you know
with creativity and
um
solving novel problems and all that sort
of thing so
um I'd like to hear your guys opinion on
what do you guys think
um on what your timelines are and even
just a little bit about what you would
what would pass as AGI for you
well that's an interesting question what
what would pass is Agi for me I mean as
far as the timelines go I actually look
at this more from a just a computational
perspective like as you guys know I've
I've ranted so many times about you know
what you need in order to have a touring
complete you know system right like you
need to have an expandable memory you
need to have some type of program that's
able to utilize that expandable memory
so for example somebody took GPT
whatever for you know GPT chat and they
hooked it up to to Twitter so it could
tweet out
anytime I wanted to in fact maybe many
instances of GPT could could tweet out
and if they could also be hooked up to
being in such a way that they could read
from those those tweets well you've now
like taken GPT and hooked it up to an
external store right so you have this
effectively an expandable memory you now
have what could amount to a turing
complete system right the trouble is
training because GPT wasn't trained for
that context and the trouble is training
neural networks that operate well in
that context and that gets all to this
issue we talked about so many times and
I hope we're going to talk more about
you know symbolic AI in the future but
you know you need to have this bridge
between symbolic and connectionist
capabilities because as you take
connectionist architectures which are
easier to train or easy to train even
for that matter and you start adding
more and more functionality to them so
they become more symbol-like then they
become really difficult to train right
and I think once somebody nails that
like once somebody really finds a way to
effectively bridge between
symbolic architectures and connectionist
architectures and effectively search
over that much larger program space once
that technical hurdle is is a cross then
ask me again you know how long it'll be
before we get AGI because it probably
won't be long after that honestly yeah
yeah
I think from my perspective I mean Keith
and I have had a bit of a puritanical
approach to AGI when I spoke with Robert
Miles I was intellectualizing it I loved
the philosophy of intelligence and we
intuitively think that the world is
exponentially complicated and you need
to have lots of computation power to to
you know perform intelligence and what
we've seen with language models and many
approaches to intelligence is that very
very simple methods work and then here I
am Mr philosopher saying well it's not
really intelligence it's not really
reasoning it's not really planning and
Robert Miles said well the thing about
fire is it can kill you and I don't
really care whether it's intelligence or
not and there seems to be this gulf
between what I perceive to be the actual
phenomenon of intelligence and what
these models are actually performing now
it's difficult to deny that regardless
of whether they're really intelligent
they are doing things right now that
appear to be and for all intents and
purposes are intelligent so yeah there's
a little bit of a gap in my mind and the
pro problem with the AGI discussion is
that I don't know for sure I don't know
for 100 sure that it's not going to
happen but I do think that there are
more pressing problems and also I don't
like the notion of a timeline because
how the hell can you put a probability
or a timeline on this it's such a
complex phenomenon it is difficult to
quantify but at the same time you can
sort of there are sort of Trends
emerging and not only that but you know
when I think we can now ai has
definitely gone mainstream now and not
only that but it's it's starting to
attract a lot of interest from you know
like the big corpse and also like even
like governments military like people
it's starting to sort of get that arms
race feel to it you know and I think
when that happens that's when things
really start to move fast so
um you know a lot of people make the you
know it's like you know 13 years ago no
one had a smartphone whereas now every
you know you can't live with that one
basically so like things do move fast
the technology space and now that we
have now that ai's kind of out of the
bag so to speak I think that it's pretty
clear that it's going to move very fast
and it probably does make sense to start
sort of
um sort of projecting timelines as to
when you think that you know the human
level AI systems are going to be here so
you know
I do I get your point there to see like
I think I think it's definitely valid
that um
it's about capabilities really like you
can you can argue until the cows come
about whether it really is intelligent
or whatever but because intelligence is
a pretty broad it's a bit of a buzzword
it's not really meant to be a precise
term it's just meant to capture our
intuitions about how humans act and all
that so
um
if an AI can as long as I know I can do
it if I can plan if it can solve
problems if it can you know
classify images if it can do everything
that we want well yeah we could be
pretty fair to call it AGI
but um
yeah I don't know what else do you want
to go with that well I I do just want to
comment there that
you know sure AGI is is difficult to
Define I like chalet's definition of
of uh general intelligence you know
probably the best so far but I think as
you pointed out
it is possible for AGI or not AGI it's
possible for AI to cause lots of harm
well before it gets to AGI so you know
yes there is an arms race right now for
weaponizing AI I mean you see articles
about it every day and and that in and
of itself is is pretty scary so I think
that we do need to focus a lot of
attention onto AI safety even before we
get to
AI alignment and we you know we really
need to do both and I mean I've been on
record despite what some people think in
a recent you know podcast multiple times
like uh advocating for that but the
alignment issue specifically is you know
the alignment as you could call it
because uh many people have pointed out
that you know humans aren't aligned and
they really aren't you know like if you
look at our governments the world over
they're stacked with corporate interests
that really don't represent like the
interest of the public at all you know
so
um
that's true but we've been dealing with
human beings uh you know for tens of
thousands of years right so that's kind
of a known so our ecosystem if you will
has stabilized around
multiple groups of unaligned you know
human beings operating and we already
face existential risk votes like from
that alone I mean nuclear Armageddon you
know for one we Face existential risks
from the cosmos I mean this
eventually right we could get hit by an
asteroid Comet at any time a super
volcano we Face existential risk now but
I think the point is you know Jacob this
is a new one like it's a new one that
we're introducing and and you know we
should at least understand it better
before we we really open the box I think
is is the argument right well the box is
already open but we should we should
rapidly try to understand it as well as
possible yeah yeah I think we shouldn't
spend too much more time on this but one
thing that we discussed with Schmidt
Uber and even Chomsky yesterday if you
folks can look forward to those
interviews when we release them is that
um there is a bit of a monolithic view
of humanity uh you know because we we
say it's going to kill all of us us
means everyone right and um if you think
about it we're already pretty diverse
and there's this whole thing about
transhumanism as well which is that you
know are we just a stepping stone to
augmented humans in the future might we
slowly become the things that we're so
scared of right and we wouldn't
necessarily be one cohesive body of
humanity anymore there'd be lots of
Divisions which are so
um Stark it might be as well it might be
as if there are other species of of
humans living at the same time so would
it still make sense to use the same
Narrative of it's a single entity and it
wants to kill all of us
yeah well it it really depends on how
this thing plays out you know whether
we're going to get like sort of one
one sort of autonomous agent that just
kind of does its own thing or whether
we're going to have like some it's going
to be much more distributed you know
we're going to have lots of these things
doing their own thing and
um yeah I don't know I for me it's a bit
kind of it's probably a bit premature to
talk about that particular aspect of it
like it's
um if you look at like chit chat jbt and
all the examples that we're looking at
now are distributed so there's probably
a good reason to believe that you know
like the what what comes next will be
too so in that case I don't think it's
going to be you know like one sort of
monolithic
you know Behemoth that kind of like has
its own goal to like you know be a
pay-per-click maximizer or whatever the
you know the usual tropes are
but um yeah so I don't know outside I
don't really have much to speculate on
that to be honest
yeah and this is word so look uh I think
there's a failure of imagination
oftentimes on both sides of this
existential risk argument and I think um
you know Jacob we were we were kind of
talking a couple days ago and you
brought up this this annoyance you have
with the ants you know argument I think
it can explore this a bit so why don't
you why don't you lay out you know kind
of your version of the the ants
discussion and I think we can talk a bit
about this lack of imagination sure well
you know
a typical argument you hear from like
the um like the the Duma kind of crowd
is that you know like can
an artificial like a a super intelligent
entity is going to view us the same way
that we view ants you know like so
when we come across ads on our
construction site we don't think about
the ants we just bulldoze them and build
whatever it is that we wanted to build
on you know but I know I think they're
they're analogy is a bit off there
because you know if we if there was like
a dog or a cat or a cow or you know
anything
closer to what we would consider like
you know sentient life
we're not just going to Bull those
through the cow or the horse or the dog
whatever we move it out of the way or
whatever you know what I mean so like
and humans do ascribe value to animals
even though they're vastly less you know
intelligent and capable as what we are
you know like people love their like
dogs and their cats and all that and
they you know they treat them better
than what they treat Some Humans you
know what I mean so like
um I don't think it's like it's a bit
dishonest to just immediately assume
that anything that's intelligent is
going to view anything less intelligent
as like you know a being that isn't
worthy of Rights and all that sort of
stuff so yeah well that's that's a
similar argument to what um made when we
had him on the show he said you know in
his opinion that a hyper intelligence
would evolve you know a moral sense and
ethics and appreciate you know other
life forms and that that could be true I
approach it from a little bit different
angle and this is you know again me
Playing devil's advocate here for the
purpose of like doomers like refining
their arguments right because I ask
questions like if I came up to if I if I
had a construction site right and
there's a cow on there I'm just going to
shoot away I'm not going to grab a stick
of my Dynamite
you know and blow it up because then I
just get blood and guts like all over my
construction site I don't need it for
construction materials because I have
much more effective efficient refined
materials that I've created there I
don't want to waste a stick of dynamite
like on the cow because I'm using it for
other things right like it's not the
most efficient use of my time and
resources to blow the cow up it's more
efficient to move it and the responses
back are things like well you know if
you were in hyper intelligence you
wouldn't be using a stick of dynamite
you would be using a stick of
stringomite and it just like turns the
cow into like back into Strings that you
can then you know Harvest for energy you
know I mean like Quantum strings or
whatever it's like okay at that point
we're just talking about God right and
you get into all the same
Perils of discussions about God where
you're outside of science now it's like
well why would God do that why wouldn't
God do that you know it's like we need
to refine our arguments a bit otherwise
people will perceive them as just silly
if we don't actually address kind of
just these basic you know efficiency
arguments yeah well then of course
another basic one is just the fact that
you know ants didn't create humans you
know like in cows and dogs didn't create
humans whereas this thing is going to
fundamentally view US differently
because we created the damn thing so it
has to at least respect us on that level
you know if it's this Ultra intelligent
thing we were smart enough to make that
Ultra intelligent thing so it's going to
be it's a fundamentally different
relationship to what we have with ants
and all the other creatures on Earth
yeah on on that though um I I uh I
almost don't like admitting this but you
know some philosophers think there's
such a thing as a moral fact that's
called a moral realist and a lot of this
is is it hinges on your notion of evil
and it hinges on this notion that we
believe that we can you know deduce
these in kind of empirical or maybe
they're not empirical maybe they're
Universal moral facts and the reason why
we don't do bad things is because we are
in possession of these moral facts
and what if that's just rubbish and also
there's a very very kind of fine line
between being a moral relativist and
being a nihilist right because I think
that's part of the reason why I don't
care that much because I kind of think
that it's just the natural progression
of things and what what are we going to
do about it but is that just nihilism
well on the first point I do think that
like
moral facts actually they do have some
um basis in reality in the sense that a
lot of it is ultimately grounded in the
way that agents want to be treated
themselves right so an agent knows that
it doesn't want another agent to blow it
up for example so it via analogy it can
then extend that to the other age and
say well since I don't want to be blown
up it probably doesn't want to be blown
up either so that that's kind of one uh
factual kind of grounded
um like way of reasoning that where you
can derive like morals and like uh you
know your own sense of morality and all
that and what you should do and what you
shouldn't do in society and you know we
live in a multi-agent environment and we
all have different goals and stuff and
that's kind of the origin of um of
ethics and Mars it doesn't just kind of
come from the earth it's not something
that's necessarily like programmed
directly into us and you either have it
or you don't have it like it's kind of
these are things that can reasonably be
derived from observation and like just
you know your own reasoning about how
you should interact in a multi-aging
environment so it's not as if like
ethics and morals and stuff are yeah
like a purely philosophical things that
float in The Ether they are real they do
have like you know um grounds in reality
yeah and I I have a similar view to that
which is I think a lot of our ethics and
morality have effectively come out of um
Game Theory not not that we applied to
Game Theory but more just game theoretic
consequences of a multi-agent you know
evolving system with with agents that
had to survive or they would no longer
be around and so for example things like
cooperation right I mean there are there
are circumstances in which just
circumstances in physical reality where
you have multiple agents you know acting
where cooperation is is the path to
survival right and so that's why we've
we've kind of come up with or not come
up we've evolved and been endowed with
these Concepts because they aid and salt
it's very complex you know game
theoretic situation that's right
creating rules which you know uh help
all agents survive helps you survive as
well
yeah yeah that's why I like it as much
as I got pillow read for it you know my
comment about like wouldn't the uh hyper
intelligence that learn to cooperate
with humans you know have an edge over
the one that that uh didn't like all
these things that I ask you know they're
even though they may be simplified for
one reason or another they're based on
you know some thought behind it folks
they're not just like pulled out of thin
air yeah I mean this is a live
discussion so you know it's not as
formal as a normal mlst I mean let's
just say it Duggar got destroyed in the
comments on the Robert Miles video it
wasn't a pretty sight it's a comment
section have been really really nice to
us until quite recently and it's an
ideological issue and I think it's um
convolved with lots of other things but
yeah obviously this is something that
people really hold dear to their heart
and unfortunately ad hominem is the the
first approach when you know when your
ideas get attacked
and and look in the grand scheme of
things I have a lot of sympathy for
you know those concerned about AI risk
what I'm trying to get them to
understand is uh just ranting and raving
and standing around with leather-bound
copies of lessron.com and calling
everybody else stupid and making fun of
the way people look and their face and
their Grins and pretending they can mind
read why people are grinning is all like
when you as soon as you do that like
your arguments are automatically uh like
intellectually failing right and they've
got to up their game right if they
actually want to succeed at getting
civilization to invest resources in this
this very real problem
yeah okay well let's make the
conversation on a little bit so um uh
Jacob obviously you're a huge symbolist
so can you sketch out the landscape you
know symbolism connectionism
absolutely well first of all like you
know
the symbolist and the connectionist
Paradigm they're roughly the same age
really they both go back to the 1950s
approximately and you know it wasn't
really until
um around about 2010 that like neural
networks really took off so they almost
laid dormant for about 60 years or so
you know like they were sort of mostly
theoretical it was you know there's some
interesting little experiments and works
done here and there in the meantime and
whatnot but they really sort of you know
shot out of the blocks
um around about you know the roundabout
2010 with the uh with imagenet and all
that sort of thing and classification
and it all just kind of went from there
now the thing is is that
that might that temps a lot of people to
think yes that means that we're on the
right path because we're making all this
progress and all that but the thing is
is that
symbolic AI hasn't yet like had its
moment like it hasn't like it it had the
same problems that connection isn't had
all that time as well which is that like
computers back then were like if you
even had access to one and basically
only universities like in the 1970s and
like only really universities had
computers and they're you know like not
everyone who had all these ideas about
Ai and stuff was able to even operate
them and all that so there was lots of
things getting in the way of you know
actually
demonstrating the capabilities of these
systems and and really taking them to
where they could be you know so I think
that um
uh you know there's all this really
really good quality work done on like
lots of issues
um relating to symbolic AI like
throughout the to the 60s 70s 80s 90s
even on things fundamental issues like
planning and reasoning and you know
problem solving and uh knowledge
representation and even things like
computer vision like just there's like
symbolic AI is often thought of as you
know like good old-fashioned AI which is
like you know I think you can definitely
say that was a failed attempt because
they kind of made the claim more or less
that you know everything is logic and we
can boil everything down to like these
you know simple logical rules and this
is this and that is that and it's all
clear-cut and when of course in reality
it doesn't you know that that doesn't
operate well in the real world at all
and that's not to say that logic doesn't
have a place like logic definitely does
have a place in AI but it's just nowhere
near the whole story and that's kind of
where go far fell flat but go Phi is
only a very small subset of symbolic Ai
and symbolic AI covers like a huge
amount of other ground it covers program
synthesis which we'll get into in a
second uh and you know which in itself
covers almost everything just by itself
so you know um I think that
um
now that we've gone at computers that
have like so much more power and so much
more memory and so much more everything
I think that's symbolic really has it
hasn't had its Heyday and it can come
back really strong and once it does I
think once people once AI or research
researchers realize that like you know
symbolic AI has so much going for it in
like areas like planning and all that
it's going to make a huge comeback and I
think when it does it's going to blow
the connectionist Paradigm out of the
water personally
well so I would recommend for listeners
um really that the best place to start
in my opinion in exploring this topic is
you know the Fodor and pollution like
1988 paper right like it's um I just
look at what it's called here a
connection yeah connectionism and
cognitive architecture are critical
analysis right and this is this is what
really lays out the distinction and look
honestly I had to read that paper a few
times and I had to read like sections of
it multiple times it's it's very deep
it's very technical but it's worth
understanding it because it lays out
kind of these two poles and approaches
to things and I agree with you which is
that there is going to be a back you
know a pendulum that's going to swing
back and forth between the two
approaches But ultimately I think both
are needed like I think uh you know I
think that they're they're two they're
two ends of the same Spectrum which is
trying to automatically program by
trying to find ways to search the space
of All Pro all possible turing machine
pro programs right and I mean turing
machine in an abstract sense you know
this the space of all possible effective
programs right in some in some way that
that's efficient and produces programs
that that we can use and and you know
learning to navigate that space better
and better and developing more Tools in
that search space are absolutely the key
to AGI in my opinion okay well yeah in
my view I think that um that like the
symbolic approach is is sufficient and
that we can do away with neural networks
altogether and I think we would benefit
from doing so as well because neural
networks do have like a lot of pretty
major flaws such as like they're
incredibly inefficient at what they do
um like you know you you would have like
seen like some recent papers that came
out which kind of go into like you know
how long it takes them to come up with
like an algorithm which can enable them
to do addition it doesn't even do it
perfectly and the algorithm that they
derive is some crazy ridiculously long
like stream of like trigonometry
equations and like in functions and all
that sort of stuff it was bizarre
um just to just to add two numbers
together right whereas a symbolic
architecture just goes bank and just
does it in a nanosecond and doesn't need
to train and doesn't need to do anything
else
um to do that
so
um well can we can we explore that just
quickly though too because I see the
dichotomy as being mostly around
learning and intelligibility now in
connectionist methods we can do
gradient-based learning uh which is
Extreme I mean it's unreasonably good
right but it produces these horrendous
networks that are unintelligible which
do quite stupid things and have clear
computational limitations you said
yourself you referenced that thing from
Neil Nanda the mechanistic
interpretability uh researcher we've got
a four-hour interview with him about the
Trump by the way
um but yeah they do they do crazy things
but then um some people say that oh well
you can take a language model and take a
symbolic decomposition of it you know
which is intelligible and understandable
well that's not clear at all so we might
still have the complexity problem but
then we have a search problem right if
we want to actually find the best
symbolic structure to do what we want to
do and that's very intractable and that
gets us into discrete program search yes
exactly and so
the reason I have like the reason I
think this way is because when you think
about it like anything that runs on a
like a digital computer is ultimately a
symbolic program so this includes neural
networks themselves right so at the end
of the day neural networks uh uh their
program which you know they execute a
bunch of ultimately primitive
instructions that are from the
computer's instruction set to implement
all these you know trig functions and
like activation functions and they
Computing gradients and gradient descent
and blah blah all that kind of stuff
and so at the end of the day
human beings created those programs
right so we symbolically created those
programs to achieve a certain goal so
that's kind of the process that we're
trying to automate itself right so I
think too many people sit down and
they're like oh yeah we need to solve
this problem we need to solve that
problem but they're not they're not
solving the matter problem of problem
solving itself you know what I mean like
we need to create a program which can
take as input a goal a description of
what it is that you want to do and it
does it it creates a program which which
implements that functionality and that's
what we do with neural networks that's
what we do with everything right even
like even programs that have nothing to
do with AI like games and you know word
processors and any program for that
matter calculators so you know so that's
why I think that I'm an advocate of you
know I think everything revolves around
planning
um like in planning and program
synthesis as far as I'm concerned are
the same thing like because you know a
plan is a sequence of operations which
achieve some goal and that's exactly
what a program is a program is a
sequence of instructions in a computer
which manipulates data and performs
actions and achieves a goal so planning
and program synthesis are the same
concept it's just that you know you
might use the word program for a plan
that's executed by a machine instead of
a computer instead of like a human being
right humans execute plans computers
execute programs at end of the day same
thing you know so that's why I think
that um what's really needed is a
is is to put the emphasis back on
planning on the on creating uh sequences
of um operations which achieve goals and
once you do that that's kind of the Crux
of AGI and um at the moment we're sort
of not really I mean if you look at
recent trends like there's the Voyager
paper which is where you know like
you've got this large language model
which is now kind of generating being
used to generate programs and store them
in a library and then they use those
like um programs to act in certain
situations that have been identified as
the ones as the correct ones for them
and all that that's that's the right
type of that's the correct direction
that I I think we need to keep going in
but I think we can do away with all the
the neural stuff and just kind of you
know they understand that they can
clearly see the value in that like you
know having a library of programs for
achieving things is you know is where
they want to be and it's and it's it's
producing results which are vastly
superior to just you know running a
neural network or a or a language model
directly on the on the problem itself
like you know getting a language model
to uh you know play Minecraft is just a
bit of a mess like it takes eons and it
doesn't give particularly good results
so if we can replace that with a program
that can do all of that instead
oh I just think there's there's there's
there's orders of magnitude efficiency
gains uh available and just orders of
magnitude ineffectiveness as well
yeah so I look I have sympathy for that
that point of view I mean and it's a
great it's great and Fair Point to make
that every single neural network that's
running today is running on a symbolic
architecture uh you know I've made this
point before like it is all it's running
on symbolic architectures it was
programmed by a symbolic architectures
but again what we're really talking
about is by programming and planning is
navigating the space of all possible
programs and where I where I depart from
you is like I 100 percent see the value
in in the in the traditional direction
of of uh program construction you know
and human beings you know doing it and
algorithms that might be able to do that
say dream code or like similar types of
things I still think there's value in
the in the kind of other direction which
is the steepest you know or uh forms of
gradient descent in a differentiable way
to um you know find programs that are
accessible via that means and I think
they actually there's there's things we
can learn from both approaches and and
they can continue to approach kind of a
middle ground where we get the best of
both worlds but I'm 100 on the page that
that way too much of our resources are
skewed in One Direction currently you
know because of just whatever
politics and natural you know Hardware
Lottery and like everything else good
old-fashioned yeah
yeah that that's what helps get the fun
but I think we need to maintain a
trickle a trickle in both directions or
not a trickle we need to maintain you
know flows in both directions if only
for uh you know giving some due to uh
open-ended search that you know Kenneth
Stanley might advocate for like we don't
know like we don't know where greatness
can come from and I think it can come
from from either direction and different
kinds of greatness and we need we need
all of them yep okay so let's move the
discussion on to knowledge
representation now a lot of people
associate gofi with handcrafted
knowledge stores and this is the thing
that rich Sutton warned against in his
bitter lesson essay not just
handcrafting knowledge doors but also
hand crafting any anything including
inductive priors whether it's cemeteries
or whatever he thinks that we should
just rely on computation alone so are
you advocating Jacob for
um I mean first of all there's the
grounding problem that's a big problem
in semantics and knowledge right which
is to what extent does this knowledge
actually Grant to stuff in the physical
world and then there's the question of
how do you acquire or learn it and does
that happen automatically
yeah so that's one of the reasons why I
advocate for symbolic is because
it's sort of it's inherently grounded
because you know
if something like let's say if something
moves in the environment how do you
detect how do you know that something
moved well you need a function that
tells you that it moved if a function
doesn't tell you that it moved well then
you don't know that it moved okay so
like we have these
uh these functions which these cognitive
Primitives they're often called in the
literature where you have these
primitive functions which are designed
to capture things that are that are
truly sort of fundamental about the
universe and the environment that we
live in which you can't do without right
you can't sort of learn them you can't
do anything because they're too they're
too fundamental so they can't be derived
from anything else so they're kind of
like atoms if you like you know
everything in the world is made of these
little like particles or whatever and
they you have these Primitives and they
all add up to what we see around us and
all that so the same thing is true of
with cognition so you've got these
primitive Concepts and these which are
implemented by functions so and that's
what grounds them as well so
I don't see any
um Conflict at all with the grounding
problem in fact it's probably the other
direction that doesn't really that
struggles with grounding because
they're trained sort of almost purely on
like statistics and like you know
one of my biggest problems I have this
kind of ties in with the language
problem too by the way so I guess we
might as well go into that now as well
so you know with language models that
are trained on like on human texts right
that text has already been generated by
humans right so humans started off like
you know modern humans are about 100 000
to 300 000 years old somewhere in that
ballpark right so
there was a time when there were no
words there was a time when you know
there was no teacher someone had to
utter the first word someone had to
point at something and say rock and
someone had to point at something and
say stick you know so and that's what
language models are missing I think like
human beings have the ability to
observe and interact with their
environment and themselves like an
introspect on their own thought
processes and all that they can give
names to things too and they give names
to things that they and Concepts that
they find during their perceptions and
their observations of an environment so
when something moves from point A to
point B they they create a word that in
that encodes that that transition so
there's basically there's States and
there's transitions between states so
like that's where you get your your
nouns and your verbs and then you've got
like words that describe things like the
color of an object and all that and
these are all things that
we don't learn them because you know the
color red is the color red you know I
didn't create the color red or anything
like that and neither did anyone else
it's just kind of a name that we give to
something that was that our brains
automatically do for us so yes a lot of
it is automatic and
it's not as if I don't like you know I
don't disagree entirely with what
Richard Sutton is saying like I think
that he's correct in saying that
too many
symbolic attempts have failed because
they've they've started too high level
right they've said I think this is how
it's going to be and I'm just going to I
want to achieve this goal and I'm going
to you know
you know there's a lot of stuff beneath
that which which it should be built on
but I'm just going to ignore that I'm
just going to jump straight to the
conclusion and I'm going to hard code
all this stuff which gets me there you
know so that's a problem and I think
he's correctly identified that but if
you
if you avoid the straw man that that's
what go for that what that's what
symbolic AI is and that you know that
there can't be a low level approach
where a bottom-up approach where you
start with your Primitives and you've
successfully build up from there and
that's really what the the true
um symbolic AI approach is that would
lead to AGI not something where you kind
of aim for the stars immediately and
just kind of there's always stuff in
between that's kind of just hard coded
away and like swept under the rug you
know
right so I'm going to pause for a quick
question from architect architect we
love you
um huge supporter always see your um
your love hearts on on our comments so I
appreciate that
um so they said that intelligence of
involves the capacity to acquire
knowledge adapt to new situations and
make informed decisions and this
involves higher order functionality
meaning mating uh meaning making
reasoning and rationality and while
computation deals with the processing
and manipulation of data intelligence is
associated with recognizing patterns
making inferences and exhibiting
flexibility over various domains so they
said how do you best differentiate
between information and data or between
intelligence and computation
well intelligence is a specific type of
computation right so not all
computations result in what we would
call intelligence you know so a
calculator does computations but it's
not really intelligent per se it doesn't
know what's going on around it has no
introspection abilities and and so on
and the distinction between information
and data
um I suppose like that really comes down
to information is data that you know the
meaning of basically like if I show you
like if I hold up like a picture of like
a bunch of ones and zeros you're
probably not going to know what that
means right whereas to someone that does
know what it means it goes from being
data to being information because it
informs them of something basically so
information is data that's in a format
that you understand that you can use to
achieve some purpose
a similar a similar view there and it's
kind of you know this is one of my
favorite topics too so if we take if we
take you know yeah data is just it's
just you know statements right and and
and zeros wants whatever information is
a structuring on that okay knowledge is
the mapping of those structures to a
probability so it means you you've
created relationships between those
those information you've assigned you
know probabilistic weightings and
Analysis to it right intelligence is the
ability to map knowledge into action
so what do I need to do in order to
achieve you know certain goals okay yeah
that's that's how I would Define it and
then I would say you know so an
intelligence is also the ability to
answer questions
and for those out there who want a wax
philosophical wisdom is knowing what
questions to ask
right but the thing is that because it
was actually quite quite a clever
question because
um knowledge is is reasonably easy to
Define and I agree with Duggar
intelligence I mean we're not going to
go down a rabbit hole on that we've got
a special show coming out on it but you
know it's a very complex phenomenon and
Chalet of course says that it's not a
static skill program it's the ability to
produce a skill program efficiently
taking under consideration the you know
the conversion ratio is about the
complexity of the program that can that
can describe and generalize well note
that my definition is compatible with
that because I'm saying because the
skill program is a thing which
determines actions
yeah that's true but I just mean that
chalet's definition is just one of many
definitions and uh I mean Kristen for
example has this underlying principle
talking about you know preserving your
own existence uh but anyway the the
other component of architect's question
is about meaning and meaning is even
more Willy isn't it because how do how
do meanings emerge and I of course
believe they're Observer relative I
believe computation has a meaning which
is Observer relative that's what
Professor Mark Bishop said to us so a
chess computer can be used to perform
different tasks in different situations
so it doesn't have a universal meaning
yeah so all knowledge and meaning is
kind of more of an interaction between
data and the functions that process that
data you know what I mean so like if you
took a file that was an image and you
fed it into a loudspeaker it's going to
come out as a whole bunch of crappy
noise that doesn't mean anything you
know what I mean whereas if you take
like a file that was supposed to be that
was intended to be played as a music
file and you put it through like you
know the function that converts it into
sound waves then you'll get something
that sounds like it was supposed to be
you know and so it's really just an
interaction between data and the way
that it's processed like data the
meaning of data in some sense is given
purely by the way that it's processed
yeah okay
we've got another question there I think
from Clockwork Luke right
now you go for it tiger oh sure so so he
said uh would you compare these
cognitive Primitives to neocortical
columns
um you know say Allah Hawkins uh how do
you think the brain is symbolic at some
level of abstraction maybe on the column
level rather than the neuron level
I do yeah I think that it's ultimately
symbolic even at the lowest level
personally I think it's
um
I I think that you know one of the
things that I find funny about neural
network like artificial neural networks
is that like people
they're only meant to be a very loose
analogy like there's if you ask a
neuroscientist we know well how similar
are the two they'll say they're not very
you know so I think that there's there's
still too much that we don't know about
the brain as well like but we know lots
about low-level neurons so we know lots
about like you know we've got like
equations that Define like how neurons
work down to the cellular level and all
that and then we've also got these high
level lots of high-level knowledge about
how the brain works at large like you
know we know that the visual cortex is
here and we've got like an auditory
cortex here and these regions of the
brain are responsible for certain high
level functions you know but there's
lots that we don't know about in between
um we haven't really bridged those two
gaps yet and that's why there's not
really much we can say with certainty
about exactly
how the brain works you've got to be
careful with brain related analogies so
I think that at the lowest level there's
a pretty good analogy between uh
neurons and transistors I think neurons
are actually quite similar to
transistors it'll turn out to be I think
it'll turn out to be that the brain is
very similar to a computer in terms of
the fact that you know inputs go in
outputs go out and do they depend on
each other so like it's it's I know I
would say that the computer is still a
perfectly valid analogy for the way that
the brain works even at the lowest level
oh yeah I mean two things on that I mean
first of all um a lot of people who you
know cognitive scientists rail against
computationalists and we actually looked
into this the other day and I think what
they actually mean is that the mind is
not a computer they don't necessarily
mean that the world or the universe is
not a computer so when they talk about
the the cognitive ecology they're
basically just saying that the
computation is is outside of the mind
but also coming back to Jeff Hawkins we
interviewed him and of course you should
watch the interview and we shouldn't um
conflate discrete with symbolic because
you can think of the brain as being
discrete in many ways and you can think
of um the the cortical columns as being
discrete representations but Hawkins
thinks very much as an empiricist he
frames the Thousand brains as very much
a blank slate with you know minimal
um cognitive priors built into it and I
don't think it's really fair to say that
it's doing kind of symbolic
generalization and manipulation of
variables in the way that a symbolist
would say that it was
yeah well I believe that it is actually
like I believe that it is like you know
um doing computations on variables and
modifying them over time and and like
you know I think that kind of and one
thing that kind of shows that is that
you know humans do One-Shot learning
very well with like if I show you some
new some new object or something like
that that you've never seen before you
can your brain like creates a
representation of it stores it away
somewhere and if I show you that object
again A year later you'll still
recognize it even though you've only
ever seen it once so I think that um you
know this isn't something that
necessarily has to be built up over time
and reinforced and all that sort of
thing you know it's actually a very
discreet instantaneous One-Shot thing
you have the brain kind of encodes a
representation of it stores it away bang
very similar to how a computer would do
it actually
yeah so I think and this is why I think
the four-door pollution paper is always
a great place to start is is the the
critical thing about symbols is they
have parts
so you you can you can look at their
parts and their relationship to one
another whereas if you just reduce
everything to a voltage right like it no
longer it no longer has any parts so so
in my mind for example it's it's really
hard to see just knowing what I know
which isn't much about uh how neurons
function it's hard to see that an
individual neuron is doing a symbolic
calculation I think that the symbolic
calculation has to be at the level of a
cortical column and or you know kind of
up up from that up from that level yeah
but the key here is that if you if you
throw away all the parts if you throw
away all the structure of a thing okay
you can no longer do symbolic operations
on that thing it just becomes like you
know a point really but yeah I suppose
actually I didn't really fully answer
that person's question either about the
um the cortical columns thing so yeah I
mean cortical columns are made of you
know a thousand or you know thousands of
neurons and all that so like if you
think of one near there's like one
transistor one transistor and a computer
can't do much you know obviously you
have to combine them together into
circuits for them to do something
interesting so yeah in that sense I
would say that things like cortical
columns do in code
cognitive Primitives essentially yeah
and even like stacks of columns and
interactions between columns can combine
together to encode more complex Concepts
so yeah I would say that um the cortical
columns probably do
um encode basic things like whether
something moved or not and all that
so um didac asks the question which is
related which is what are cognitive
Primitives is it like a Bayesian pry
Walid Saba has spoken about this a lot
this is what he calls Universal
cognitive templates and he gives the
example of contains in or located at and
he said that there are Universal rules
as well so an object can't exist in the
same place at the same time yeah but I
argue with him about that one a lot so
but
um but to you Jacob I mean what what do
you use it because these cognitive
Primitives this is this is a lot of
influence from cognitive psychology this
idea that we have a baked set of
Primitives which may or may not be
Universal and it's only through
composing and traversing those
Primitives that we can think or even
conceive of anything correct yeah that's
what I believe and I think it has to be
that way to be honest like I can't see
how else that it wouldn't be because I
mean it's like um once again I know I'm
probably I'm probably overly overly
relying on on this analogy but you know
with computers you know like
there's only a handful of small like you
know instruct like instructions in a
computer like Edition and subtraction
and jumps and blah blah but using those
Primitives we can combine to make any
program so it's the same concept applies
with human beings we have like this
ability to detect for change like if I
show you this
a bottle moved across the screen how do
you know that because you've got a
function which detects okay it Compares
two frames this is what it used to be
and this is what it is now you compare
the difference and if it's different
then it changed so that's what that's
what change means so we have these
Primitives which these functions which
encode those Primitives and if we didn't
have them
I think would be stuffed so
um we have these like low level sets of
Primitives which kind of go all the way
down you know like there's addition and
then there's like you know bit twiddling
and all that and it's hierarchical so it
builds up you start with these really
the smallest possible things which are
bits basically and operations on those
and then from there you get addition and
multiplication and blah blah blah and
you get ever increasing a
never-increasing hierarchy of complex
complexity and it all starts from the
from the lowest level so it from a bit
it's John Wheeler's it from bit
basically
cool yeah and so yeah and I look at it I
look at it the same way which is the
cognitive Primitives or
um there are these these basic like
structural functions relationships I'm
sorry
that you know over time have been
endowed into us right by Evolution and
whatever else that that appeared to be
you know or that are useful they're
useful computations for us for us to
perform and their their lowest level you
know one so an example is metonymy you
know the that one thing maps to another
thing okay uh containment you know the
idea that you have a thing which
contains other things and has parts that
you can you know take out so it's these
kind of like basic you know if you're if
you're like a lisp programmer or uh or
scheme you know and you're thinking
about in those terms like you have cons
where you can do binary set for
formation which is what Chomsky talks
about as a basic primitive so binary
step formation is another one like there
are these kind of basic operations that
you can perform you know on on the
representations you have which may be
symbolic for example those are what
these these cognitive Primitives are but
they occur at more than one level of
abstraction I believe so for example I
would personally call the idea of
translation and variance a cognitive
primitive like so your brain has the
idea that that a thing a system can be
here and it can be somewhere else in a
3D space which is also a cognitive
primitive by the way like the idea of a
of a three-dimensional space it can be
here and over here and be the same thing
right and you can kind of see children
learning these these Primitives as as
their their kids right and and
experimenting and learning about if you
hide an object under something it's
contained and if you remove the
container the object's still there again
I haven't lost my piece of candy that's
yeah that's what I think is meant by
cognitive Primitives
cool so we'll take another question and
by the way it was myriology not um
autonomy is that part whole relationship
thing
um so uh Philip says do you think it's
possible to understand complex neural
networks is mechanistic interpretability
feasible
um I think no
having spoken with Neil the other day uh
I don't mean to trivialize it neural
networks are incredibly complicated
we're dealing with these models and
forms of computation that are beyond our
cognitive Horizon we're kind of playing
with these knobs and levers and we're
tuning these optimization algorithms and
we're producing these artifacts that we
cannot understand and all we can do is
test them in a variety of different ways
a mechanistic interpretability is when
you take a cross-section
and you try and understand something in
isolation but it's not really giving you
a holistic understanding so um Jacob
what do you think
yeah well I would say that um if the
addition example is anything to go by I
mean you look at the Edition and look
what it produced and then there are
things that are just you know orders of
magnitude more complicated than a simple
addition operation so I would hate to
think what it looks like uh when you map
it all out symbolically to to see holy
look what this thing's actually
doing you know so I would say that it
kind of it seems a little bit
dangerously on the intractable side to
really truly understand what's happening
in a large giant neural network you know
so I don't know I think it's a bit of a
lost cause myself and even if you can do
it I don't think that it's particularly
practical anyway so
um you might be able to fit like you
know if you wanted to understand this
one thing that happens in a neural
network sure you might be able to spend
a lot of time and resources and stuff
figuring out what that one thing does
but what if you want to know everything
you know what I mean so
um the the complexity just kind of goes
up from there so I don't think that it's
probably a very um tractable way of
going about the problem
what other questions I got
got some time anybody have anybody have
uh some killer questions do we miss any
well um Howard said I feel you guys
should all read the impossibility of
language acquisition and how they do it
which was a paper at the annual review
of linguistics so thank you very much
for that Howard we will definitely check
that out
by the way Tim linked um you know if you
guys don't know about the uh Stanford
Encyclopedia of philosophy uh that's
it's the most dangerous rabbit hole for
me uh you know because I'm sort of an
armchair philosopher I'm not I'm not
trained as a philosopher but I go to
this uh Stanford encyclopedia I can
disappear for hours you know reading
reading articles there it's it's a
really fun website that in an online
Etymology
um yeah it's amazing and actually when
when we uh spoke to Chomsky yesterday
about
um rickenstein he said no Wittgenstein
is completely irrelevant all you need to
do is go to Plato you know the Stanford
encyclopedia and look look at the
Wittgenstein entry and just look how
little was written there and that's all
you need to know that was his that was
his answer
um and also on the myriology thing the
only reason that's fresh in my mind is
because I asked that to Carl friston in
respect of Gollum you know hinton's
Gollum is a cognitive architecture an
inductive prior that looks at part whole
relationships I want to quickly touch on
Salvador Dali who said that have we
spoken about full cognitive
architectures like jeppa yes we have
watch the um I think it's about a
50-minute intro that we did on that on
the beginning of the first Chomsky
episode so go and check that out um
sorry Jacob you were saying
oh no it's all right I wasn't actually
standing but um there are lots of
interesting cognitive architectures out
there which are definitely like if
you're interested at all in AGI you
really have to look into these
architectures like some of them
um like aren't what I'd say are quite
there in terms of you know what's needed
to get us to AGI and all that but
they're still instructive nonetheless
obviously there's saw which is like
that's one of the oldest ones from John
LED and that's actually still being
actively worked on and his work is still
good like even outside of that because
he goes into he's written a lot of
papers on just cognitive architectures
themselves like what they need to
contain and what they need to be able to
do and all that sort of thing and
another
bike name job I should probably worth
it's worth um listening is Kristen
Thorson he does a lot of really good
quality work on cognitive architectures
and he has his own cognitive
architecture called era which goes into
like a lot of the stuff which I don't
know we didn't quite have time to touch
on today because we've got it now but
you know he's it's all about autonomy
like it's it's all about you know
automatic goal generation setting goals
and you know which are a function of
what the agent knows as the agent learns
more about its environment and itself
and everything else it can set new goals
which in an ever expanding Horizon so it
starts small and it just keeps on going
and going and going and getting
recursively self-improving it can modify
its own uh instructions and its own
architecture it can introspect to itself
and its code is all available to itself
so it's it's got like the instruction
set of its of the code that it's written
in is available as knowledge to it so it
knows how its own machine works it knows
how to manipulate those instructions so
yeah it's really worth checking out
honestly like and that I think that's
probably the main thing missing in
today's AI is the fact that there's not
enough emphasis on Agency on
um on cognitive architectures on
automatic goal setting and just autonomy
in general there needs to be a lot more
of a focus on all of that
also and I can vouch for Kristen uh
thorison he's a professor at one of the
universities in Iceland when I was
reading up about intelligence he's
written extensively about intelligence
and I got him to record a five-minute
video which we have inserted into our
upcoming documentary on intelligence and
we're going to interview him again soon
but anyway um this draws uh to a close I
I'm afraid but if you folks like the
live format it's it's a little bit more
impromptu and less formal than than
usual if this is valuable to you we do
have some lives coming up we've got two
with Connolly he next week one with
Joshua Bach and one with Brady Bunch who
gave the touring lecture about 10 years
ago so you know two very very big folks
I'm also going to do another one with
Connolly he in person but still alive um
I think the at the beginning of July
with David Foster so we've got a few
things lined up anyway thank you all
very much for joining and we'll see you
soon
yeah this was fun bye-bye